- So, in what some are calling
the copyright decision of the century
in Google versus Oracle,
the Supreme Court has sided with Google.
This is a case that
involved Google copying
some code related to
Oracle's software in an API.
Now, a lot of people are saying that
this means APIs are not copyrightable.
That is not actually true.
The Supreme Court didn't
reach that decision.
Instead, it focused on
the more narrow question
of whether Google's use
of this API code was fair use.
And the Supreme Court said
that in this particular case,
this was considered fair use,
that Google was only using a small part
of the implementing code that
was used for other purposes,
and went through all the
other fair use factors
and found in Google's favor.
So we'll see what repercussions this has,
and how this affects the
copyright ability of software.
Will you have to do a fair use analysis
anytime you take someone else's code?
We'll see,
and I'll see you in court.